When you absolutely, positively have to have
Jonah Hill for your tentpole picture, be prepared
to pony up some major cash.
The star, who is in talks to appear in writer/director
Matt Reeves' The Batman in an undisclosed
role, is reportedly seeking a figure equivalent
to twice what the flick's star Robert Pattinson
will pull down.
"Uh, don't forget about my money."
Variety film reporter Justin Kroll disclosed
the tidbit on Twitter, adding some context
to the news that Hill is being eyed for a
role in The Batman.
Exactly which role that is has been kept under
wraps by studio Warner Brothers, but it's
been speculated by many that the star could
be cast as the Riddler or the Penguin.
According to Kroll, this is dead accurate.
Kroll wrote,
"So on the Jonah front, he's had the offer
for over a month and besides money being a
bargaining point (at one point heard he wanted
10 which is wild since Rob isn't making half
that) but also which character he would play,
whether its the Riddler or Penguin."
There's quite a bit to unpack there.
Kroll states that Hill has been sitting on
a firm offer for more than a month, which
could be taken to mean that while he's still
technically "in talks" for the role negotiations
have stalled somewhat.
The reporter also asserts that at one point,
Hill was asking for a whopping $10 million
dollar payday to appear in The Batman, but
it can be inferred that he's not going to
get it.
If Warner Brothers were cool with coughing
up his reported asking price, there would
be no reason for Hill to have been sitting
on their offer for this long.
"I'm not understanding.
How much money you make?"
It's likely that the studio countered with
a figure more in line with what Pattinson
will be making, which Kroll says isn't even
half of $10 million dollars.
It has to be pretty close, though.
Superhero salaries for a first solo picture
tend to fall within the $3-to-$5 million dollar
range, and it's safe to say that Batman is
a pretty high-profile property.
By way of comparison, it's been reported that
Brie Larson was paid $5 million dollars
to star in 2019’s Captain Marvel, while
Benedict Cumberbatch pulled down right around
$3 million dollars to lead 2016's Doctor Strange.
We haven't even gotten to the last part of
Kroll's tweet, which is perhaps the most interesting
of all: apparently, a major sticking point
between Hill and Warner Brothers has to do
with which character he'll be playing, which
could imply that the two parties aren't seeing
eye to eye on the matter.
"I'm not stupid.
I'm smart.
I make million dollar deals."
Physically speaking, the Penguin would be
the most obvious role for Hill, since the
actor is relatively short at 5-foot-7.
He lost a significant amount of weight back
in 2011, so he's not the Oswald Copperpot
of the comics, but he still can't shake the
fat jokes …
"When Jonah's agent told him that Quentin
Tarantino wanted him to be in a spaghetti
western, Jonah was like, 'You had me at spaghetti.'"
It seems likely that the Penguin is the role
that Warner Brothers has in mind for the actor,
while Hill, perhaps sensitive about his weight,
is more keen to take a crack at portraying
Edward Nygma, the Riddler which seems like
a pretty good fit to us.
Hill may be known primarily for his comedic
roles, but he is a gifted, Academy Award-nominated
actor, and we can absolutely see him bringing
just the right notes of cunning and madness
to the role of Nygma.
Reeves has said that he'll be fielding a more
grounded, noir -influenced take on Batman
than previous filmmakers, so while it may
seem a little on the nose to cast a comedic
actor as the Riddler, Hill has proven that
he has the chops to to add a bit of comedic
flavor to the role without overwhelming it.
It remains to be seen how the month-long stalemate
between actor and studio will be resolved,
or indeed, if it will be at all.
It's obvious that Hill and Warner Brothers
began their negotiations pretty far apart
on what the details of the actor's contract
would be, and it's not like there aren't dozens
of thespians in Hollywood who would fall all
over themselves for the chance to play either
of the roles Hill is reportedly being eyed
for.
Of course, we'll be keeping our eyes peeled
for any developments, and we'll keep you up
to speed.
The Batman is expected to begin production
late this year or early next, and the flick
swoops into theaters on June 25th, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.